E aí
[Música]
eu nunca um game é jogado de duas
maneiras
inclusive pela mesma pessoa assim como
Heráclito já havia dito que ninguém se
banha duas vezes no mesmo Rio Então o
que será do mundo pós uma situação dessa
na qual estamos vivendo
e hoje eu tô aqui nessa breve jornada de
alguns minutos para podermos falar sobre
a convergência dos caminhos de um gamer
e de um professor e falando em Jornada
eu gosto muito das palavras de pronúncia
quando ele diz que o caminho do
conhecimento não vem de novas paisagens
mas sim novos olhares e dessa razão eu
vou falar duas palavras que todo mundo
conhece e sabe muito bem o que que é
jogos e educação
é
dessa maneira
como tudo na vida quando a gente resolve
aprender quando a gente resolve estudar
o encontramos universos infinitos
encontramos autores
livros e ideias
e nem sempre existe um consenso entre
tal
pensamento então daqui para diante
Quando eu falar em jogo vocês vão pensar
naquilo que vocês possam jogar podem ser
jogos digitais com aplicativos ou
consoles jogos analógicos clássicos ou
modernos práticas como Sudoku palavra
cruzada regras que você mesmo inventou e
até mesmo aquele desafio do Tic Toc
dessa maneira
Qual é os jogos
dessa maneira existe uma outra coisa em
relação aos jogos eu gostaria de dizer
eu não acho que os jogos são como se
fossem a vida
é a vida não é um jogo
respeito quem diz porém não concordo
os jogos fazem parte da vida na equação
da vida o jogo ele só é uma variável que
só vai ter benefícios quando bem
entendido no seu devido lugar
por falar de vida também tem a questão
de educação
bom e quando eu falo educação eu gosto
de pensar nas palavras do educador do
século 20 chamado de do Cristo na morte
Quando Ele Diz Que Não Existe diferença
entre educação e a vida e se existe é
porque alguma assimetria necessita ser
resolvida
e quando começamos estudar essa jornada
entre jogos e educação Encontramos uma
teoria chamada ludo literacia
e esse é o primeiro. Essa teoria disse
que para aprendermos vai jogar para
começarmos a jogar necessitamos aprender
como as peças funciona o que fazem os
botões e depois que aprendemos
continuamos nos esforçando para aprender
jogar bem e para vencer isso na minha
opinião se aproxima muito
do que eu chamo de Santo Graal da
educação o aprendizado autônomo o fato é
que nem todo mundo que joga conseguiu
desenvolver autonomia de aprendizagem
talvez aí existe um campo fértil para um
professor e um gamer
e não importa o período da humanidade
Que Nos olhamos
e sempre vai haver a motivação para
jogar
hoje e sempre vai haver a necessidade de
aprender e com isso também as desculpas
para não fazer lição de casa estudar e
tudo mais
e se olhar para o futuro que eu não
tenho muita coisa para dizer me baseando
nas palavras de Garota Nenhum Heart Ele
disse que com as mudanças culturais que
acontecerão durante o período de
pandemia nas próximas décadas a
tecnologia vai evoluir centenas de anos
Mas uma coisa eu me arrisco a dizer
Essas tecnologias
certamente serão testadas serão
popularizados frente ao público
através dos jogos para o passado eu
gosto de criar um exercício de abstração
de 150 mil anos atrás África no ponto
onde hoje se localiza a Tanzânia Av 12
de nossos ancestrais
um que gostava de atividades lúdicas e
outro que não mas por favor quando eu
falo homosapiense e atividades lúdicas
não é para imaginar homosapiense no
jogando PlayStation Xbox One PC gamer
os jogos e atividades contextualizadas
com o seu nível tecnológico o respectivo
frente a um desafio qual dos dois teria
maior capacidade de sobreviver
e eu arrisco dizer que seria aquele que
jogava pois ele possui ia uma memória
muscular capacidade de improvisação e
até certo nível de sociabilidade
liderança talvez agora no presente você
esteja pensando jogo Logo Eu sou bem
vivo e eu digo não porque naquela época
o jogo se assemelhava muito aqui o
fraude e falava do bebê da carretilha o
jogo para entendermos um ambiente no
qual vivemos o jogo hoje nesse momento
inclusive numa era de Big Data
ele traz uma linguagem comum talvez a
relação com o jogo EA competitividade do
mundo seja em entender o jogo mas
analogamente ao jogar e sobreviver
Talvez hoje a palavra seja adaptação vou
dar um exemplo de educação
e os professores acostumados com a aula
frontal com o palco italiano se viram
obrigados a ir para casa e no dia
seguinte transmitirem as suas aulas
igual streamer YouTubers já faziam com
os jogos e veja só a quantidade de
ferramentas a quantidade de aplicativos
e práticas comuns aos gamers passaram a
incorporar rotinas tanto corporativo as
contas polares vou dar um exemplo os
ambientes 3D os meta versus
multiplicou-se o número de instituições
faculdades museus que começaram a
utilizar meta universos
é mas quando a gente fala do caminho de
um gamer com professor essas respostas
elas não vão estar expressas em
estatísticas e números na qual nível ela
todo mundo em dados elas estão em
narrativas elas estão histórias e para
isso eu gostaria de trazer duas
histórias para vocês primeira delas anos
80 uma criança que tem uma semana que
foi uma verdadeira montanha-russa
primeiro ele ganhou um atalho
depois ao se recusar a fazer o alfabeto
que a professora tinha pedido Afinal já
tinha aprendido a ler e escrever sozinho
e ele é compulsoriamente mandado fazer
exames neurológicos como forma de
punição ouvir o que os exames não
demonstraram nada não sei o Óbvio como
uma interatividade que são de atenção
mas nada que prejudicasse a vida dessa
criança o fato é que a criança triste e
a mãe tentando com todos seus esforços
melhorar o humor
fala para que ele escreveu uma cartinha
para o cometa Halley que naquele momento
passava pela terra e a criança redigiu ó
querido Cometa da próxima vez que você
voltar para terra eu lhe prometo que
terei histórias melhores para contar só
que a criança não tinha noção do ciclo
do Cometa já já eu volto para falar da
Criança e do Cometa
o anos 2000
é um professor de uma disciplina regular
a ver uma arbitrariedade feita
e pelos gestores de uma determinada
escola
é contra um grupo de alunos os
prejudicando
e esse professor desistiu de da aula
desistiu de um mestrado que estava quase
concluído
e em pouco tempo depois sofreu um
acidente
entre as dúvidas e angústias de precisar
voltar andar de tentar encontrar uma
nova sustentabilidade um novo it Guy
para sua vida
e ele resolveu comprar um videogame e
jogando em pouco tempo ele falou nossa
mas isso é muito legal Poxa preciso
compartilhar essas coisas que eu tô
vendo na tela e ele criou um blog em
pouco tempo o blog começou a ter
milhares de visitas por dia Ele se
tornou uma referência chegando até mesmo
apresentar suas ideias para líderes de
estado
é igual a esse professor Eu também sou
professor que insiro com os jogos
e eu vou compartilhar para vocês a minha
receita Eu sempre faço três perguntinhas
quando eu vejo um jogo
a pergunta número 1 o que que esse jogo
me ensina o que que eu posso aprender
com esse jogo pergunta número 2 como que
eu vou compartilhar o que eu tô
aprendendo
a pergunta número 3 O que que você
aprendeu com esse jogo minha ideia mas
sua ideia uma terceira ideia e agora
nesses tempos eu também tenho mais duas
perguntinhas como que os jogos podem nos
ajudar nesse momento no qual estamos
vivendo e o quinto é se você já jogou o
foldit muito além de ser um jogo muito
legal trata-se de uma iniciativa da
Universidade de Washington na qual o
jogo extrapola o próprio jogo quanto
mais pessoas jogam mais dados são
gerados e mais bases para cientistas
médicos modelarem as informações e
trazer em tratamentos para doenças
inclusive ano passado foi criada uma
fase específica relacionada ao
coronavírus
tá chegando aqui na conclusão eu
gostaria de deixar uma reflexão quando
era adolescente os jogos vinham em
cartuchos como esse
bom e quando o jogo trava e o sistema
tinha algum problema a gente tirava ele
do console e as o brava
eu colocava ali no console G1
eu esperava o console ligar
é analogamente hoje quando o sistema
atualiza o jogo para Mas a vida não para
e talvez a terra o sistema do nosso
planeta esteja muito carregado porque
essa atualização
está demorando muito
é mas
a reflexão que eu quero deixar aqui é a
seguinte
é diferente
daquela história que eu contei dos dois
personagens que foram postos de um modo
de espera
individualmente agora o mundo foi posto
em espera coletivamente
estamos todos na mesma linha de partida
no final de um epílogo no começo de um
novo prólogo é porque não
pensarmos
no que está por vir no meu caso eu vou
pensar na relação de jogos de educação
e como eu havia prometido talvez algum
de vocês já
conseguiu fazer a conexão e entender
Quem era criança e o professor talvez
estejam perguntando mas como eles estão
agora e eu posso dizer bem aqui nesse
palco
com isso nós temos uma questão
e foi feito uma promessa para o cometa
se o cometa passa-se hoje parafraseando
Shakespeare eu poderia dizer que foi uma
vida de games e fúria uma história
contada por um bobo qualquer mas na
verdade eu diria que eu
ensinei como Gamer
eu joguei como professor e sempre me
esforcei para viver como ser humano
o que tive experiências de vida
fantásticas como essa só que o cometa
vai passar daqui exatamente
39 anos e
277 Dias
caso eu não esteja mais aqui quando o
cometa passar e vocês se lembrarem Conte
a minha história para ele muito obrigado
a
[Música]